so the senate has just passed the 40
billion ukraine aid bill joe biden is
expected to gleefully sign it very soon
11 republican senators voted against it
in the house 57 republicans opposed the
bill one of them was texas congressman
chip roy here's why he said he voted
against it
when i hear the majority leader of the
other party say quote a time of war when
i sat with the majority leader in a
rules committee meeting upstairs and he
said we're at war and i'm wondering when
we voted to go to war
and people we're going to have a proxy
war and we're going to get 40 billion
dollars to ukraine because we want to
look all fancy with our blue and yellow
ribbons and feel good about ourselves
maybe we should actually have a debate
in this chamber a debate in this body
because the american people expect us to
do that
so that's the majority of you in the
country that's what most people think
it's not at all what the leaders of both
parties think and they are absolutely
united in this
ukraine's borders are not just more
important than our borders but they're
so much more important that they're
spending 10x protecting ukraine than
what they're spending protecting this
country from fentanyl pouring in in
human trafficking because that's what
they care about
roy is the main you just saw from texas
he joins us tonight congressman thanks
so much for joining us tonight um so
you were one of relatively few to say
this i i think you're probably speaking
for the majority of your constituents
are you not
yeah no question tucker i've got nothing
but uh positive feedback from all the
people that i represent in texas who are
just sick and tired of business as usual
in washington and look you you posed the
question to senators look i had five
hours to make a decision about that bill
i didn't think it was that hard you
posed a question to senators that you
know asked them to come on your show to
defend the vote did any of them take you
up on it not one
not one yeah of course not because it's
indefensible to fund 40 billion dollars
unpaid for at a time of rampant
inflation in our country in effect
you're basically pouring five dollar
gasoline on the runaway fire of
inflation for the men and women who
you're working hard throughout this
country and senators are now hiding
behind saying oh 40 billion dollars
isn't that much money tucker 40 billion
dollars isn't that much money and you
know what they're saying they're saying
take a leap of faith and make sure that
we put our faith in the brass at the
pentagon the same brass that walked out
of afghanistan leaving 85 billion
dollars of equipment behind walked away
from bagram the same brass that told us
two months ago that kev would fall in a
week why are we following that uh the
senate should be ashamed of itself
passing a 40 billion unpaid for bill
while the american people are suffering
with rampant inflation and now you know
what's happening in the house you have
my colleagues in the house who are
coming up to me and saying oh chip you
guys in the freedom caucus are daring to
force votes on a bunch of bills and
making us vote we missed eight
fundraisers this week fundraisers tucker
oh oh i'm sorry did we interfere with
your steak dinner rather than doing the
work for the american people that's what
the american people are sick of in this
town they're being manipulated by the
intel agencies they're telling you you
haven't seen the intel
these people are idiots
they believe what they read scary it's
really scary i appreciate your bravery
congressman chip roy of the state of
texas thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight